Speaker 1: This is a crazy story out of Australia.
We have we have quite a quite a few viewers
in Australia.
In fact, it's one of our outside of the U.S..
I mean, it makes sense.
It's a lot of English speaking countries Canada,
the UK and Australia, where we have some of
the biggest audiences and close to 10 people
sent me this story about Australian anti-vaxxers
completely fabricating the death of a boy
from Sydney, Australia, supposedly from the
COVID vaccine.
It turns out it was completely made up.
This is being reported by seven news in Australia,
as well as a number of other media outlets.
A distraught Sydney father has shared how
his beautiful seven year old boy died in the
back of an ambulance days after being vaccinated
against COVID, but authorities say it's a
hoax.
In a lengthy Facebook comment, Steve Leary
claimed his son Lachlan received his first
vaccine dose on Wednesday.
Is that a popular Australian name?
Because this isn't one of Rupert Murdoch's
kids also named Lachlan.
Lachlan received his first dose on January
12th, experienced a fever and difficulty difficulty
breathing shortly after he claims he took
his son to Westmead Hospital, where they ran
tests and after five hours sent him home.
Friday morning at four a.m.
We heard him yell out he was on his bedroom
floor.
He then collapsed.
He was not breathing, wrote the father.
He claims his son died of a massive heart
attack and warns other parents not to vaccinate.
The government has ruined my family.
They have taken away our only son.
I mean this.
This is tragic, if true.
The post quickly gathered pace online, collecting
thousands of likes, comments and shares before
the profile was taken down and the post reshared
as a screenshot.
But it's believed to be the latest case of
misinformation running rife, a deliberate
attempt to discourage parents booking in to
get their children vaccinated.
Less than a week after five to 11 year olds
became eligible for COVID vaccines in Australia,
there is no record of a Lachlan Leary who
died in Sydney last week or indeed at all.
NSW Health told 7NEWS it quote has not been
able to locate any record of such incident
and the therapeutic goods at.
Ministration, which collates all adverse events
associated with vaccines, also rubbished the
claim.
In a statesman statement, a spokesperson stressed
it has not received any adverse event reports
involving the death of any children between
five and 11.
The Children's Hospital at Westmead also refuted
the reports in writing, saying there are many
inaccurate posts currently circulating on
social media.
There is no record of any child having passed
away following COVID vaccination at our hospital.
There are also questions surrounding the validity
of Mr Leary's profile.
News of the death pictured Leary, a man who
lives in the United States and served as the
mayor of Winter Park, a small town in Florida.
This is this is this is really immoral, and
everything we believe now indicates that this
is merely a hoax meant to dissuade parents
from going and getting their kids vaccinated
against COVID.
We are fortunately seeing the decline of a
micron now in the United States cases down
about 21 percent as of this morning.
We are seeing a leveling out globally.
Many individual states in the U.S. are down
significantly, but.
One of the groups that is most getting seriously
ill on a rate basis is the very young, most
of whom have not yet been vaccinated.
And this is again, it's another opportunity
to move to the endemic phase.
It endemic doesn't mean no risk.
But it means something different than pandemic.
We have an opportunity.
Part of it is getting as many people protected
from getting seriously ill.
You might catch it, but you're much less likely
to be seriously ill.
Five to 11 year olds are part of that.
And this appears to be an out and out complete
and total hoax.
And I hope that at least as far as the U.S.
is concerned, this reminds people when you
hear about Veirs reports where tens of thousands
of reports about kids dead from the vaccine.
Those reports are completely unverified.
Anybody can go and submit a report to Veirs.
Now people will write and they'll say, David,
it's a crime to do that.
Is anybody getting prosecuted for that?
Have you heard of anybody being prosecuted
for submitting a false report to Veirs that
is not dissuading people from doing it?
They are weaponizing the Veirs report, which
is the vaccine adverse effects reporting system.
I assume the Asa's system, so an incredibly
pernicious moment.
And I am not advocating one way or the other.
Australia has different laws than the United
States.
It remains to be seen whether this individual
may face some kind of penalty.
Of course, if he really lives in the United
States, it's not really clear that anything
would apply.
But we're going to follow the story.
That's everything we know right now, and we
will have a link to the story and more information
on our Instagram, which you can find at David
Pakman show.
T